before we go we've got a pick from the
little yellow book and today it comes
from our favorite young intrepid
reporter emmy eaton take it away emmy
okay so my pick is a podcast called what
if world it's a podcast for kids each
episode is a fun what a story like what
if cats or the world or what if a tiny
dragon lived in my closet drew ross what
would you do if a tiny dragon lived in
your guys's closet move out that's what
i do
yes renovate just run away go live on
the street in new york
i got too much clothes actually my
friend uh dr eliza pressman um said that
if a parent is like struggling with
their kid and monsters in their closet
you can try and make a monster spray oh
and put it in right drew if your kids
ever have a really messy room you could
say well if there's a monster in your
closet they like it when
it's dirty so just clean your room and
then it will not then they won't be here
anyway
well i know what i'll be doing tonight
um thank you emmy for that really great
parenting advice
um i really love that what if podcast
because if cats ruled the world or what
if i emmy and took over ross and drew's
job that's going to happen one day
by the way i don't doubt that i believe
it and
right here thank you for joining
us thank you
take this energy with you have a
fantastic day
[Applause]
[Music]